all right now before we talk about what
looked like one of the most compelling
movies of the year i want to thank the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by skillshare skillshare
is an online learning community where
millions come together to take that next
step in their creative journey no matter
how much you know about something
there's always
more to learn skillshare is there for
you in that journey really creative
endeavors like illustration graphic
design photography animation creative
writing music film and video and so much
more as i always say that's just the tip
of the iceberg right there and i
appreciate the fact that since no two
people's busy schedules are the same
skillshare allows you to learn based
around your own schedule and i
appreciate that they have the class
interior design interior decorate like a
boss because every time i think i make
my place look awesome people come in
they're like yeah
the bachelor lives here all right
decorating your place to look like it
has class
such an underrated talent so click the
link below because the first 1 000 of my
subscribers to do so will get a free
premium trial membership and thank you
once again to skillshare for sponsoring
this video
i do appreciate it
so the green knights directed by david
lowry it's a fantasy film starring dev
patel
where i mean as seen in the trailer this
enigmatic green knight character shows
up and he's like hey king how about one
of your knights fight me and
if he lands a blow on me great dev
patel's like i'll do it he lobs off the
green knight's head and the green
knight's like
one yeah
hence so that's this movie one year
later death patel's character goes on
his quest to find the green knight and
make good on the promise and
fulfill his end of the bargain now the
green knight set in the world of king
arthur dev patel's character
in the story of the green knight is king
arthur's nephew and i bring this up
because if you didn't know that
if you didn't google it if you haven't
run across that little factoid
or tidbit if you don't hear a youtuber
talking about it in a review
for this movie you wouldn't know by
watching the movie this movie could have
really heavily relied on the king arthur
element to sell this movie a bit more it
could have had these really obvious
winks nods and references in the movie
but
it never does that succeed or fail this
movie chooses to stand on its own
as its own story rather than lean really
heavily
on the more famous property it derives
from i respect that now first of all
death patel in this movie is great we
know he's a great actor but you have to
address it because we've all seen that
movie where the great actor
you watch it and you're like okay they
were there for the paycheck
i get it though this movie is directed
by the director of a ghost story i don't
think you team up
with david lowry to be like hey i need a
really good paycheck today and that's
why
like that's the sole reason no you
probably team up with this director for
the sake of taking part
in the process of creating cinematic art
but dev patel was great because largely
this is his movie the movie's on his
shoulders as well
not just his shoulders i would say that
the world that we're traversing
in this movie is a character in and of
itself and that to me other than
dev patel crushing it and letting you
get into this world the fact that
you are in this world because of him
that's what you appreciate it's an
amazing fantasy world that you just you
appreciate
going through with him in terms of tone
practical effects and
cgi it was the world of fantasy movies
needs the green knight it needs the
green knight like back in 2001 the world
of the fantasy genre
needed lord of the rings but i feel like
the fantasy genres just kind of reverted
to
pre-lord of the rings where it's like
all right yeah some of it's fine
but it's never the apex it's never the
peak that lord of the rings was
this lord of the rings is still the peak
i can see the comments right now game of
thrones am i a joke to you
no not until they passed george rr
martin's books and then
most definitely us one of the things
i've always loved about the lord of the
rings movies was the low-key display of
gandalf's magic and other magic elements
you get to the hobbit it's like oh sweet
just
cgi gandalf magic but in lord of the
rings it was much
more subtle the green knight brings it
back to that there's cgi
absolutely but it's there to complement
the practical effects there's a lot of
cgi a lot of computer generated imagery
in movies i don't feel that sense of awe
too
often but when the green knight can have
these huge giants walking
and i'm in awe like it's a set piece or
something that's pretty impressive in
terms of the fantasy tone in the green
knight when i was watching
strike that go back a little further
when i saw the trailer
i had this thought and then in watching
the movie the thought remained the
fantasy tone
in this movie should have been the tone
in the warcraft movie like when i heard
oh warcraft movie it's gonna be like
lord of the rings
this is the tone i thought of at least
the human elements i like the orcs the
humans were boring as [ __ ] i would still
love to see a sequel to the warcraft
movie but
bring the tone back to something like
this i mean it doesn't have to have the
same
pacing as this movie but you know
atmosphere and tone you know make the
world feel like this and speaking of the
pacing in this movie yeah i mean just
because you're a fantasy fan
maybe you're looking for something a
little more fast-paced this movie really
isn't that if you're looking for the
battle of helm's deep or something it's
not in here this is a slow burn
character piece in which you're in this
world
experiencing this world experiencing
this character's growth the green knight
on the fantasy end of the spectrum
very much reminds me of blade runner
2049 on the sci-fi end of the spectrum
there is that connective tissue i felt
while watching the green knight that i
felt
in blade runner 2049 right because in
both cases i
cannot say these are anything less than
well-crafted film the world
looks amazing it feels amazing you're
living in it the lead actors crushing it
the entire time doing an amazing job
that said i can't just pop in and be
like oh i just
i don't know some light watching i feel
like watching blade runner 2049 today
the green knight very much gives me that
same feeling that said the green knight
i'm glad
it's as good as the trailer made it look
the green knights
something in that fantasy genre i've
just been craving for
years it's a slow burn low fantasy high
fantasy hybrid that makes for a very
unique and welcome
cinematic experience as much as i really
enjoyed this movie i can see it getting
even better as time goes on
aging like a fine wine but as for right
now i'm definitely getting this movie
i'm buying it on blu-ray when it comes
out
also great musical score often i forget
to talk about the musical score
and it always pisses me off i upload the
video like i forgot
damn it so i'm making a point to do it
here i love the musical score
it had that fantasy flair to it
sometimes it's haunting but it never
supersedes the movie it always
complements the scenery
the world the moment you're in all
that's to say i'm sure the vinyl
soundtrack will come out for it and
i would love to get it just sit there
listening to it with my scotch
brooding it'll be fun all right so the
green knight have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you